(heartfelt piano music)
- My mom is the bomb.
We're more like best friends.
We're just always goofing off, we love to hang out together.
Like, that's my girl.
- My mom is a person.
She's vivacious, she just steps into a room,
and the whole world lights up.
She's one of the most important people in my life.
- My mom is the strongest person I know.
She's a single mom, raised my sister and I, and
has been there through a lot of hard times, for
both my sister and I, especially recently.
- I used to just be next to her when
she would be washing the dishes, and that would
be my favorite time because I would just get
to talk and tell her all the gossip in school, and
talk about nothing, really, but she was always there.
- We just have a good time together.
We're always laughing.
I can't even remember a time where I've
actually gotten into an argument
with her, or been mad at her.
We just don't have a relationship like that.
- I can tell her absolutely anything.
She has been my best friend since day one.
- We are really close.
We talk everyday.
If I don't hear from my mom in a day,
or in two days, then it's a weird thing.
- She always pushed me my hardest, but she
also had such a soft spot for me.
- My mom called me one day when I was
at work and said, "Don't freak out; I'm sure it's
"no big deal, but I have a lump in my neck."
- So, the first time was breast cancer.
The second time was ovarian, the third
time was skin, so it's been a long road.
I think being a single mom, it's that
much harder to bring bad news to
your children, and kinda scare them for the future.
- There were no signs of anything when she
had mammogram, something just didn't feel normal.
- She flew to Taiwan and we heard from our mom and our
dad over the telephone that she had cervical cancer.
- She couldn't bring herself to say
anything, it just, "Hi, honey."
and I'm like, "What?"
Like, no, it's like she's my mom.
- You know that cancer happens to any and
everybody, but when it happens
to you, it's like, "Oh my god."
And then to happen to my mother, my best friend,
it was something I wasn't ready for and I know
she wasn't ready for it either.
- I don't really remember how I felt, I
just remember being kind of like, "What do we do now?"
- My first reaction, though, was: "I'm going home."
"I need to drop everything and"
"go help her in her time of need."
- Just watching her go through it was very emotional
because I felt like I couldn't do anything for her.
- Everything happens for a reason, which
is a big mantra in my family.
I don't know how much you want me to go into this.
I was on leave 'cause I just
got diagnosed with breast cancer.
So, definitely learned a lot from this.
I don't know that I would've handled
all of this as well, if I hadn't had her
by my side for every point in my...
Every surgery, every doctor's visit, and test result.
I wasn't sure if I was even gonna talk about myself today.
You roll with the punches.
- My sister, my dad, and I were all in
the same room when it happened.
It was actually more peaceful than I thought it would be.
I had eighteen amazing years with my mom.
I feel like sometimes when things go well, someone's
gotta be looking out for me, and it's probably her, so.
- I just wanted her to know that, "I'm with you."
"I can't feel the pain that you're"
"going through, but I'm with you."
In June, my mom will be three years breast cancer free.
She's stronger mentally now because of it, and physically.
- My mom is doing really well.
She's actually healthier now than she was before cancer.
- Know that you're not alone in this process.
Unfortunately, there are a lot
of people who are battling with cancer.
Just know that you're stronger than what you think you are.
- Support systems are everything.
You know, people think it's cliche to say, like,
"Let me know if I can do anything."
And there's really nothing necessarily
you can do, except just show your support,
and show that you're there, even for something
as simple as a phone call, or coffee, just to
let them know that they have a
shoulder to lean on is really helpful.
- I wanna say something easy like, "Time will help."
But, I don't know if time has helped that much.
If someone's going through this right now,
I hope they know that the pain that they feel,
it'll come in waves, you know, and you
just have to ride the waves sometimes, I guess.
- Mom, I just wanna say that
I love you, and I'm proud of you.
The journey still continues, but you got this.
- You are the strongest, most badass person, and
I'm so proud to be your daughter.
- Thank you for being everything.
You've taught me so much about life, and
persevering and especially now,
I don't know where I'd be without you.
- I really want her to know that I'm okay.
- For anyone battling cancer, or for anyone going
through this journey with someone, there are a lot
of resources out there, annual walks, dancing events like
dancing with survivors, and then there's also like,
message boards and stuff like that.
People you can talk to when you
feel like you don't have the answers.
You feel like you're just alone battling
something that you didn't ask for, so
there's always people that you can talk to, there's
always ways that you can help others, you just have to
go to Google and search it out.
^(mellow piano music)
(squeaking hinges)